[Music]
so most of the doj's search warrant
affidavit which supposedly justifies the
completely indefensible fbi rate in
mar-a-lago has been redacted because you
don't have clearance you can't see it
but one name that is prominently
featured not redacted is that of cash
patel he's a former chief of staff at
dod from the last administration so
immediately after the affidavit was
released with his unredacted
peter strzok maybe the most famous
fbi agent in modern history tweeted this
directed at cash patel and we're quoting
never great to see your unredacted name
in a search warrant affidavit get a
great effing criminal defense lawyer
you're going to need it
so here you have permanent washington
threatening someone on twitter but
that's totally cool cause
orangemen bad like what so we thought we
want us we would like to speak to cash
patel himself he's president the cash
foundation he joins us tonight cash
thanks so much for coming on if i were
you i hate to say this to you but that i
would be very concerned about a tweet
like that from a lunatic like peter
strzok
well you know tucker is a former
national security prosecutor and is the
lead investigator for russiagate my
investigation that i ran with devin
nunes is the reason peter strzok got
fired along with 16 other fbi officials
including andy mccabe lisa page comey
and the like and their corrupt cabal is
back being escorted out the door as you
just reported on friday so the
corruption continues and their bias and
their hypocrisy knows no bounds but of
course they're shameless as a former
national security prosecutor and peter
strzok as a counterintelligence head
agent knows that american citizens names
and search warrants are supposed to be
redacted this doj with the same
leadership that authorized the russia
gate is now back in charge had gone in
to intentionally lift a redaction of
just my name and then redact the next
seven consecutive pages it was totally
for political purposes they don't care
about the threats to my life the racist
message and the hatred i see every day
now because they are publicly
advertising for me to fail to go to jail
and to be harmed and here's another
thing the fbi did this after a 10-month
investigation into death threats from
the january 6 subpoena committee on me
and on friday the same day they issued
the affidavit is the same day they ended
the investigation saying even though
they had credible evidence we could go
no further
it's it's it's just beggars belief so a
height one of the highest ranking
officials at the fbi is threatening you
on twitter
where's the current fbi director to call
peter strzok and say hey you can't do
that because you eliminate all public
confidence in this agency when you do
well the current fbi director chris wray
was the fbi director when we ran the
russia gate investigation and he had the
opportunity then to expose all the
corruption at the fbi and he failed and
he's been covering up since look we said
since the beginning we got out 60 of the
documents for the russia gate
investigation 40 remain president trump
declassified those specific documents
and this entire raid on his house i
believe was to prevent the disclosure
now that the government gangsters are
back in charge of their corrupt
activities from russia gate on down
because now that they have an open fbi
counterintelligence investigation they
will shield any red any release of
documents because they will say we have
an open investigation congress has a lot
of work to do and i'm glad
whistleblowers are coming forward they
need to be doing so uh in droves
this behavior is just so over the top
the next time a prominent critic of the
fbi has kitty porn found on his laptop
or fentanyl in his car
i don't think anyone's going to believe
it's real that's how corrupt it seems to
me and we just wish you absolutely the
best cash patel you have a right a
constitutional right to give your views
in public without being threatened
so thank you for coming on tonight
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight